team no matter how many times no matter
how many times it's always special
number one
when it when the uh your peers
the fans and your peers that's awesome
so i'm excited about tonight we always
are and and the way all-star starters
are determined has not changed
fan vote counts 50 percent uh player
vote 25 percent a media panel 25 what is
different from previous years is that
here to help us reveal the 22 all-star
starters we have a special guest special
guest she is nicole talbert from ernst
and young here in atlanta bernstein
young has tabulated the votes this year
on behalf of the nba
and has been kind enough to hand deliver
the results in this briefcase to us
thank you so much nicole for this uh
live exclusive announcement cult of the
all-star star live and direct here on
tnt so here's the deal uh in years past
we would have a little heads up you know
and when this when the show started we'd
already know we knew like uh like ten
minutes if if
you wanted to you know people would be
calling you shout out to raymond ritter
love you raymond call my friends but we
have no idea just like you all at home
who are the starters going to be we do
not know so
here we go this is envelope number one
western conference oh wait what it is
what's the conference about the western
conference
you're the first to know ernie
the captain leading vote getter in the
west
lebron james
all right
i think we knew that uh 18th straight
appearance in 2022 in his 19th season
giving the lakers 29 points a game eight
rebounds six assists shooting 52 percent
he has the most 30 point games in the
nba this year with 22 and he's going to
be a captain again and so far as a
captain he is 4 and oh jack
that's one of the greatest players we've
ever seen we've ever seen
congratulations to lebron
and his family and i just had to repeat
what kevin said we knew he was making an
all-star game yeah we talk about goats
and all that ham michael kobe shaq
you know whatever
however
he is the best
player
for the mo the longest in the nba he's i
don't think any player has been as great
as long
oh my god no not as long this is what 18
years right now
this long tell me a player this old was
this good kareem kareem karim wasn't
good no green was good he wasn't this
good this old i'll say this about lebron
if he does win the scoring title this
year and he's right there in the thick
of it he would be the oldest scorer
nobody's been this great this old i'm
not saying at 37. now he's played
long-term
we could we could debate the merits of
lebron james uh if you'd like but i
think i'd rather get to the other two
okay starters yes in the western
conference front court
nicola yokic who is the reigning mvp
this is a big this is a big one here
andrew wiggins of the golden state okay
congratulations warriors all right
congratulations
uh to jokic first fourth straight
appearance in his seventh season
averaging 26
14 and eight
while shooting 57 percent he leads the
league in double doubles and he leads
the league in triple doubles
with 11. so nicola yokic oh joins lebron
james in the western conference
front court and how about andrew wiggins
eighth year in the league
first time all-star shooting a career
best 48 percent for the 35 and 13
warriors averaging 18 points four
rebounds two assists for the 2015
rookie of the year how about that kenny
uh congratulations to andrew wiggins i'm
the first time all-star and not to
mention the job he does
yeah i think the one thing when he when
he was um
when they traded for him and i and i
think we all
you know some people laughed when i said
in the d'angelo russell right
i said going there he could be an
all-star
and
and a lot of people didn't see it but i
did only because the role would change
as the primary scorer i thought he would
be great and an all-star in a secondary
role and now being in a secondary role
his 18 to 20 points become much more
meaningful because if you if you're
counting on a guy to get 25 and he gets
20
then they're like ah but if you're
counting on a guy to get 14 and he gets
20 then he's an all-star and that's i
thought would happen you know when
you're such a young talent
they expect you to know how to win he
didn't know how to win he was up and
down criticized a lot but when he went
to golden state
similar to what javale mcgee did they
taught him how to be a winner they
taught him how to play a certain way and
he's doing that and i want to
congratulate him and his family well i'm
definitely not mad at this well number
one congratulations it's awesome but
what they really did was put him in his
right spot he can't be your best player
when he got that max deal in minnesota
you know people think
when you get max money like andrew
wiggins has got to be your third or
fourth best player that's what happened
to a lot of guys people assume when you
make money you can automatically i'm the
man andrew wiggin is a good player
but he probably needs to be the third or
fourth best player on your team to go
with those other guys and you can become
an all-star but if he's your best player
you saw what happened so he's just in a
great situation he can be the third or
fourth best player on that team and it's
congratulations yeah no doubt
congratulations all-star
and to andrew wiggins now uh next up
because you like me to show this is the
west yes now this one here is going to
be very interesting and the winner is la
la land oh no and
that's funny yeah that's good i caught
that early i caught that stephen curry
and john moran yes hey yes the starting
back court good job i'm happy for the
job west all-stars
first to curry his eighth all-star game
in his 13th season
26 points a game is number nine
he's hit at least one three and 169
straight games 14 30 point games
warriors have the second best record in
the west
and so now another first timer
at the tender age of 22
john morant uh given the grizzlies 25
points a game which is good for 10th in
the league six rebounds seven assists
2020 rookie of the year when he joins
mark gasal
as the only grizzlies
as starters
in the all-star game but he has really
come on shag you know i made a comment
the other day it sort of went viral but
i think people misunderstood what i said
so he reminded me of kobe i didn't say
it was the next hillbilly reminded me of
kobe talk about mamba mentality
his mentality and kobe's mentality is
similar he knows he's the best player in
the league that's how he's supposed to
play uh second third year
dominating you know he's definitely a
you know a box office type player people
want to see him play he's very excited
i'm very happy for him me and chuck kind
of knew this was going to happen but you
know he definitely has that mentality
where i don't care who i'm playing
against on the court this is my game and
i'm taking over you know number one uh
congratulations to john maron he's been
fabulous all year he's had a couple
little injuries but when he's here
they're first of all they got one of the
best coaching staffs in the nba but me
and kenny got to tell you this funny
story
so we were in the playoff shack like
right before but he didn't know he
didn't even draft it he just left
college so we're on the set getting
ready
for the game
and this little kid come up and say hey
mr smith mr barker i want to say hello
and we're like hey nice to meet you nice
to meet you blah blah blah and he walks
away and me and kenny said can who's
that we had no i had no idea it was a
kid who's that little kid who came
because of his size and stature yeah he
plays so much bigger he plays a lot
better we thought he was like six four
six five after watching him i thought it
was somebody had that kid that
came to the set he was like 110 pounds
you know what he remind me of like dame
lillard and not as far as the player
when i met dame little i was like i
thought he was going to be bigger than
that yeah and that's the same thing with
jock but they both are terrific players
but i'm happy for john moran i was
watching the post game show on the
grizzlies telecast last night and he
talked about hopefully being able to get
home to his grandmother's to watch the
show from there
hope he was able to do that and uh
welcome to the dark that's uh that's
exactly that's it's kind of his slogan
about all the work you do in the dark
when nobody's watching and you don't
have lights it has paid it has paid off
sure has congratulations john morant all
right so that does it for me i'm excited
to see him in a western conference
all-star setting oh